fans have been theorizing that ginjury
sudden reappearance in season seven
might have something to do with the fact
that gingers particular set of skills
could be helpful if they ever worked
I'll have to forge more Valyrian steel
swords more importantly some fans can be
of Ginji being back on the scene as a
sign that his father promised to Ned
Stark in season 1 might finally be
fulfilled remember back in the very
first episode in the Winterfell crypt
Robert Baratheon expressed his desire
that his son should marry Ned's daughter
to align their houses forever we were
meant to rule together if your sister
had lived would have been bound by blood
well it's not too late I have a son you
have a daughter Robert was talking about
Joffrey who he thought was his son and
Ned's daughter Sansa this never happened
and therefore how stark in house
Baratheon haven't been joined yet
however huge amount of fans think that
this marriage might finally happen in
the form of Robert's only son ginjury
and Ned's daughter Arya Arya and ginjury
formed a special bond way back when they
were traveling north on the Kings Road
together there's a memorable scene that
Ari and ginjuries share that might have
a share of that those two could become
family one day
let's take a look served men my entire
life I served master Mott at King's
Landing and he sold me to the watch I
served Lord Tywin at Harrenhal wondering
every day if I get tortured or killed
I'm done serving you just said you were
serving Lord beric
he may be their leader but
they chose him
he's been a brother's their fan
I've never had a family I can be your
family
it wouldn't be my family
you'd be milady
[Music]
Ginji back then believe that human Daria
could never be together considering that
she's a highborn daughter of Lord Eddard
Stark well he on the other hand is just
a bastard son of a random man or at
least that's what I thought he was back
then Ginja later found out who his
father truly is King Robert Baratheon
having in mind that Arya is in
Winterfell while ginjury on the other
hand is heading towards it with Jon Snow
in the near star garyun those two be
most certainly reunited in the very
first episode of the final season while
many fans believe Arya and ginger will
end up together many fans are also
convinced that Arya would never settle
down and have children and I understand
him after all that sutorius said herself
regarding her future you will marry a
high Lord and rule his castle and your
son's shall be nice and princes and
Lords however what we also need to
understand is that Game of Thrones is
full of irony we thought Ned Stark was
way too honorable to die but then he did
you very your honor like a suit of armor
Stark is what Littlefinger said to Ned
since that was a proper lady who wanted
to marry a prince and have many children
we know what happened to those dreams a
marriage her trial tightened she did not
want to wear again not now perhaps not
ever since us thoughts in a feast for
Krauss Robb thought bread and salt will
protect him from Walder Frey we all know
how that ended once you have a ton of
his bread and salt you have the guest
right and the loss of hospitality
protect you beneath his roof Catelyn
said Robb in a clash of kings we thought
Khal Drogo would sail across the Narrow
Sea and Vindi are enthroned for his wife
Daenerys and yet he ended up dying
before even sailing to Westeros and to
my son the stallion who mounts that will
also pledge a gift to him I will give
this Arryn share his mother's father sat
upon I will give him Seven Kingdoms
I draw a oval Doris said Khal Drogo to
Daenerys Jaime said he would rather
prefer a clean death than being alive as
a [ __ ] only to later become one and
continue with his life anyways the point
is that Arya never wanted to be a lady
while her sister Saints always dreamed
of marrying a handsome young man giving
him children and living a happy life
wouldn't it be kind of ironic singari a
girl who never wanted any of that
getting what sense always wanted we all
expect Arya to either die in a battle or
live out for days as an assassin
adventurer and that's why neither of
that will happen it would be too obvious
her getting a happy ending and living
her life as a proper lady she never
wanted to be will be a huge twist for
her or is a highly trained assassin with
a thirst for vengeance
however this point are already avenged
her family and vent wards over and White
Walkers are defeated I think that Aria
will get the life that sense I used to
dream of and ironically Aria will enjoy
that life are evil most likely end up
marrying injury and live out her days
raising their children in the castle I
have a son you have a daughter will join
our houses is the quote that has always
been on my mind obviously back then
Robert was implying that sense and
Joffrey should vet but we all know how
it all worked out for them
however dis in my opinion foreshadows
Ginjo and aria drink Baratheon and Stark
houses once and for all some fans even
claim that george RR martin and
showrunners thought of re-injury while
writing this particular scene
considering how they loved to twist
words around arya resembles her aunt
Lyanna stark ginjury on the other hand
appears to resemble his father in other
words their union could symbolize Leanne
and Robert relationship and this time
it's not one-sided love as we all know
Robert was promised Liana but it didn't
work out however Robert's son fulfilling
the promise made years ago between how
stark a house Baratheon seems fitting
Aria does have feelings for ginjury
which was made clear and she told him
that he can be her family also there
could be some clues regarding this
marriage in the first meeting between
gangi and john let's take a look on that
scene your grace is Gendry your grace
I'm Robert Baratheon son bastard son
he was meant to keep that to himself
our fathers trusted each other
Washington wait I saw your father once
at Winterfell
I met yours in my shop
you're a lot leaner you're a lot shorter
now let's take a look on this scene that
took place in the very first episode
Oh grace you've got fat
it's quite obvious how interaction
between ginjury and John is similar to
one Robert and Ned had even Davos
reminds me of Johnny rain taking injury
and John under his caring wing just like
Lord the rain did Robert and Ned also
Robert was in love with Ned sister
Lyanna just like injuries with John's
sister Arya so I'm sure you can see the
parallel now that Aria has finally
returned to Winterfell and ginjury on
the other hand has not only returned to
the show but it's also heading to
Winterfell
it just seems they're meant to end up
together I can definitely see them
living their days out peaceful in storms
end with their children I'm sure most of
you are wondering how they could live in
a castle that belongs to house Baratheon
considering that ginger is a bastard son
and therefore he's not allowed to
inherit his father's lands or titles
well there are two possibilities one is
that ginjury suborn son of Robert
Baratheon as there's a theory in which
his mother is actually Cersei Lannister
and the second possibility seems simply
getting legitimized by John or Daenerys
ginjuries a bastard son of the late King
Robert Baratheon and with no living
broth Ian's left in the show he will
most likely be legitimized by Danny if
he agrees to bend the knee and swear his
loyalty to her which ginger will most
likely do I believe that the injury will
be legitimized which strategically makes
sense to do so as it will unite the
Stormlands to the cause of Daenerys I
understand that there are some of you
thinking that Dany legitimizing injury
would make no sense some of you think
that she would be creating a potential
rival for the Iron Throne
and even if ginjury personally is not a
threat some of you think he could either
marry an ambitious woman or have an
ambitious child well Danny statements
say otherwise and I ask you not to judge
a daughter by the sins of her father
Danny as well as Jon Snow said it
multiple times throughout the season
seven that a child should not be guilty
for their father's sins and doings if
Daniel ow Tyrion whose father did more
crimes of House Targaryen than Robert
did to become her most trusted advisor I
don't see why the nurse wouldn't
legitimize ginjury if he would bend the
knee and swear his loyalty to her
anyways becoming Lord Baratheon ginjury
would inherit storms and and Arya will
most likely be his lady
well Ned was killed in season 1 which
sets of the events for the show I cannot
help but think that Nia did four share
of this marriage when he told Arya that
she will marry a high Lord and rule his
castle this marriage has also been
foreshadowed by Jaime Lannister in the
books while having a conversation
regarding the Starks with hoster Jaime
might ever share of the marriage with
my injury and Aria is that why you
killed all the Starks holster as Jamie
not at all said Jamie Lord Eddard's
daughters live one has just been bad the
other if the guts are good she'll forget
she was a stark she let some burly
blacksmith just as Robert wanted back in
the first season the houses Baratheon
and Stark will probably joined through
his son and his daughter just not really
once he and Ned thought